no longer are you a lonely human being
in a Strange World instead you are at
home wherever you go in nature you can
breathe be yourself without the stress
and expectations of others you feel at
peace with the way the world is a sense
of connection to the other creatures to
the trees the plants to the soil perhaps
even a Oneness with it all
so one of those secularists they would
say they're running in the forest and
they have this sense of
interconnectedness or connection with
the landscape and what happens Within Me
happens without and I am an entity but
I'm also connected to a greater world
and to Nature and to the other species
and to the ecological systems and to the
universe and we are all a part of this
uh this deep interconnectedness with
nature for many people goes as far as
inducing an experience where there is a
dissolution of the self a disappearance
of one's feeling of individuality and a
kind of merging with the environment
around you